con un poco de suerte ya entiendes algo
de lo que está detrás de hacer una
integral o bien de cómo encontrar el
volumen debajo de una superficie
entonces vamos a hacer un ejemplo
concreto de cómo encontrar el área
debajo de una superficie esto nos
ayudará a fijar las ideas supongamos que
tenemos z igual a x ye cuadrada esto de
aquí es una superficie en tres
dimensiones y lo que queremos es
encontrar el volumen entre esta
superficie y el plano xy recuerda que
tenemos que tener una región para
encontrar el volumen en este caso la
región está dada por las restricciones
cero menor o igual que x menor o igual
que 2 y la restricción 0 menor o igual
que ye menor o igual que 1 ahorita vamos
a ver que estas restricciones nos dan un
rectángulo déjame traer una gráfica en
3-d para que veamos a esta superficie se
ve súper padre verdad observa como aquí
abajo ya está determinada la región que
nos interesa de 0 a 2 y de 0 a 1
entonces lo que nos pregunta el problema
es encontrar el volumen debajo de esta
sábana
arriba del plano x va entonces déjame
rotar un poquito para que para que
entendemos para que entendamos un poco
mejor esta figura quiere va a poner
rotar a ver cómo se le separa usar esto
así hasta entonces lo que queremos es
este espacio que está debajo de aquí
mira con un poquito de imaginación
parece como pues como media tienda de
campaña entonces lo que queremos es
determinar el volumen del sólido que
queda debajo de esta tienda de campaña
vamos a regresar acá a las cuentas para
ver cómo lo planteamos
para empezar lo que voy a hacer es un
dibujo que no está tan padre como el que
vimos pero nos va a ayudar a trabajar ya
entender qué es lo que estamos haciendo
paso a paso
voy a dibujar los ejes aquí tenemos el
eje x por acá tenemos el eje y lo dibuje
un poco más corto porque ya sólo llega
hasta uno y aquí tenemos el eje z
entonces les voy a poner sus flechas x
iceta y entonces x va de 0 a 2 a quién
va a poner 2 lleva de 0 a 1 achille aquí
y aquí lo marcó y entonces a ver a lo
que queremos es el volumen
que esté sobre este rectángulo voy a
intentar lo mejor posible dibujar la
superficie entonces ahí va aquí al lado
tengo el dibujo entonces lo voy a
intentar copiar va más o menos por aquí
y luego sube llega aquí se forma una
esquina y luego baja en línea recta algo
así
entonces vamos a darle un poquito más de
un poco más de volumen
voy a sombrear por aquí a ver ahí te va
no voy a sombrear por aquí
esto de acá es la región de la cual
queremos determinar el volumen entonces
baja aquí sombreando voy a dibujar aquí
arriba con amarillo la parte de arriba
de la superficie y entonces creo que
paso menos se ve se ve muy parecido
verdad entonces lo que lo que nos
interesa es encontrar el volumen fíjate
más o menos más o menos me quedo bien
verdad entonces ahí va
entonces cómo le hacemos para hacer esto
entonces lo que hicimos en el vídeo
anterior es tomar una arbitraria y para
eso vamos a fijarla eso nos va a dar un
corte de las de un corte del sólido que
queremos encontrar y con ese corte ya
simplemente queremos encontrar un área
entonces ahí te va esto de aquí es un
corte entonces sobre esta y queremos ver
dónde corta al sólido entonces más o
menos quedaría una cosa de este estilo
ahí va y ya teniendo una fija ya tenía
una fija lo que queremos hacer es
determinar cuánto vale el área que está
debajo de esta curva sí es decir si
hacemos un corte con un plano con una
fija entonces nos determina un área
después vamos a sumar todas esas áreas
pero por el momento esto se convierte
esto aquí se está bueno digamos con
llegó a las cinco nos queda se está
igual a 25 x y eso de ahí es una curva
de la cual podemos encontrar sus
como si fuera una integral normal y está
entonces vamos a hacer eso vamos a
ponerle aquí que tiene un cierto valor
de x la base y la altura de cada uno de
nuestros rectángulos va a ser una
función una función zeta verdad que
depende de dos variables de xy de gec
entonces a ver el área de cada uno de
estos rectángulos es nuestra función
efe de quique que en este caso es zeta
es decir x de cuadrada multiplicada por
por el ancho que es de x entonces si
queremos encontrar el área lo que
hacíamos y lo que hemos estado haciendo
desde hace un montón de tiempo es tomar
la integral
de dónde a dónde pues de dónde se mueva
la equis desde 0 hasta 2
ya tenemos una expresión para el área de
un corte
esa es una área nada más ahora lo que
queremos hacer es sumar todas las áreas
conforme vamos cambiando el valor de
compra vamos haciendo distintos cortes
entonces ahí va el área de debajo de
esta curva está dada por esta integral
eso de ahí nos da una función de iu pero
vamos a darle un poquito de profundidad
al área que encontramos para que se
vuelva ahora como una rebanada de pan
delgada multiplicando la por de y
entonces una cosa que era pues digamos
una cosa que sólo tenía área ahora ya se
convirtió en algo con volumen fíjate
aquí teníamos una rebanada lo voy a
multiplicar por un pequeño cambio en g y
eso le da volumen va entonces vamos a
multiplicar por d para darle un poco de
volumen y si queremos encontrar todo el
volumen debajo de la curva queremos
sumar todas las áreas que ya las
convertimos en volúmenes y entonces lo
que queremos hacer es integrar
a 0 hasta allí igual a 1
entonces aquí le ponemos 0 aquí le
ponemos 1 si te quedan dudas todavía
sería buena idea que checar as el vídeo
anterior y cómo le hacemos para evaluar
esto pues ya es muy muy fácil
simplemente tenemos que ir evaluando
desde adentro hacia afuera va entonces
déjame marcar esta integral de aquí para
indicar qué le vamos a hacer primero
entonces hay que integrar pero con
respecto a hechos es decir ya es una
constante porque únicamente estamos en
una integral con respecto a x cuál es la
integral de xy cuadrada pensando allí
como una constante pues a ver es una
función muy fácil no te dejes engañar
por la y simplemente nos queda x al
cuadrado entre 2 y como llegó a través
una constante nos queda aquí afuera
ahora lo que hay que hacer es esto poner
sus límites de integración
y todavía nos falta poner la integral de
0 a 1
bella
va entonces cuál es el valor de esto si
ponemos x igualados tenemos 2 al
cuadrado entre 2 2 al cuadrado entre 2
nos queda haber es 4 entre 2 que nos
queda 2
entonces nos queda 2 cuadrada lo voy a
poner por aquí todo se cuadrada y luego
hay que restar la función evaluada en
cero cuando x vale 0 pero 0 al cuadrado
nos queda 0 entonces nos queda menos 0
que no lo voy a escribir ba y entonces
ahora que nos queda fíjate que esta
expresión nueva ahí te va esta expresión
ya la podemos integrar con respecto al
de 0 a 1 quiero poner de iu porque ya es
una función de y es una integral de las
facilitadas de las facilitadas facilitas
que hemos hecho desde hace un buen de
tiempo entonces fíjate
esta superficie lo que ya obtuvimos es
que para una fija el área de esta
superficie el área que está debajo de la
curva de aquí es 2 ye cuadrada eso es lo
que nos dice la primera integral que
hicimos entonces esto de aquí acabó
siendo una función de iu lo cual tiene
todo el sentido del mundo pues cada
corte que hagamos nos va a ir dando un
área diferente en el caso de esta
superficie más o menos cómo va quedando
esto pues si tomamos un corte muy
cercano a un 1 entonces quedaría muy
grande y un corte muy cercano a cero nos
deja un área muy pequeña pero bueno ya
teniendo una función de jett podemos
hacer la integral con respecto a esta
variable
entonces vamos a hacerlo otra vez es una
integral polinomio al que está muy fácil
cual es la anti derivada de dos y
cuadrada pues nos queda a ver ya el cubo
entre tres por dos dos tercios del
cúbica sale y eso de ahí tenemos que
evaluar dos de cero a uno a ver cuando
le ponemos ya igual a uno nos queda dos
tercios por uno al cubo que es dos
tercios y luego hay que restarle un cero
entonces la respuesta final
dos tercios listo con esto terminamos
dos tercios es el volumen debajo de la
superficie dos tercios que pues si
fueran metros entonces serían dos
tercios de metros cúbicos vale entonces
este de aquí fue un ejemplo pues más o
menos más concreto de cómo podemos
encontrar el volumen debajo de una
superficie ya después hablaremos de
algunos ejemplos un poco más complicados
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo y hasta
pronto